I volunteer as tribute it's a dystopian
terrifying look at the future of the US
and one of the most popular movie
franchises in history you've got a
fascist future where a small minority
controls all the wealth the children
dissent and free speech are non-existent
and rebellion is punishable by death so
what makes the Hunger Games film so
popular
sure Katniss is hot Peeta is cute he's
cute he's just not hot and the idea of
kids forced to kill one another in an
arena each year is insane but it's the
political messages fans find in the
story that has them obsessed regardless
of where they lie on the political
spectrum to them The Hunger Games
forecasts a dangerous future that may
lie ahead for folks on the left it's the
nightmare of income inequality where
wealth is concentrated in the hands of a
tiny elite which is actually not too far
from our current reality where the
richest 1% own 40% of all the wealth in
the United States and have only gotten
richer since the 2008 financial crisis
for conservatives The Hunger Games
serves as the ultimate warning against
big government up in everyone's business
controlling resources and trampling on
the rights of states and citizens then
there are the ever-growing fears of the
police state which have become all the
more real thanks to Snowden's
revelations that NSA surveillance has
made our private electronic
communications well not so private
but the biggest theme of the new film
Mockingjay is the role of media as a
tool of propaganda as the rebellion
against the Capitol grows both sides
video clips to sway public opinion
Katniss is recruited by the rebels for
anti-government videos designed to go
viral
meanwhile PETA who's been captured by
the government makes video statements
denouncing the rebellion
lay down their weapons now kinda gets
you thinking about what you see on your
own TV screens the primary target here
was the Corazon de Corazon terrorist
group some Hunger Games stars have even
drawn parallels between the films and
real-life Jennifer Lawrence said she
sees similarities with the hostage
videos released by Isis Donald
Sutherland whose character President
Snow actively tries to crush the
rebellion said he hopes the films get
young people thinking and working
towards change so will you if so may the
odds be ever in your favor
[Music]
you